bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france comment circule le
virus chez les élèves quels sont les
retours de parents que vous avez
l'épidémie et elle maîtrise et dans les
étapes dans les établissements scolaires
comme l'affirment le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer
mais écoutez merci de m'éviter j'en
crois que justement nous avons entendu
les chiffres et il est aux gens à mon
avis de d'être calme et de prendre les
éléments avec beaucoup de sang froid
effectivement nous avons entendu qu'il y
a eu par rapport à la semaine passée
plus que le triplement du nombre de cas
mais en fait je dirais qu'il faut être
aussi circonspect dans la mesure où il
est possible que dans la première dans
la semaine précédente en tout cas les
chiffres que qui ont été communiqués ne
rochette ne reflétait pas correctement
la réalité donc le point sur l'épidémie
je dirais qu'il est encore trop tôt
attendons encore avant donc d'avoir une
idée plus précise de l'évolution de la
contamination est ce que le masque est
suffisant aujourd'hui dans les
établissements scolaires est ce qu'il
faut davantage de tests qu'est ce qui
est prévu pour limiter la propagation
dans les établissements alors je dirais
que par rapport à la quantité au nombre
d'experts entre guillemets qu'il y a en
fait et qui se positionne sur la
question je voudrais tout simplement
dire que nous à la peine nous pensons
qu'il faut revenir aux fondamentaux
étant donné que différentes différentes
solutions différents différentes actions
d'être prise
il faut revenir vraiment aux
fondamentaux et les fondamentaux c'est
quoi le port stricte du masque le
respect des gestes-barrières avec bien
entendu
la nécessité qu'il y ait des moyens qui
est des moyens dans les établissements
scolaires en gel hydroalcoolique etc
et puis surtout organiser le nom
brassage des élèves alors qu'ils se
croient en 100% ou bien 50%
il faut surtout éviter le brassage et
donc on a vu par exemple sur le terrain
qui a des établissements quelquefois
avec une population d'élèves très
importante à saint-etienne par exemple
1600 un établissement avec 1600 élèves
où on continue à organiser le fait que
ce sont les élèves qui se déplacent pour
aller dans les cours suivants plutôt que
les professeurs donc je dirais que nous
en appelons sur toi des mesures il ya
des comportements de bon sens des
comportements de bon sens qui s'il était
respecté nous permettrait peut-être de
sentir un peu plus tôt de cette
situation catastrophique
aujourd'hui il est indispensable de
laisser les établissements scolaires
ouverts
oui nous avons vu disons les effets du
confinement
premièrement justement sur la santé
psychologique de beaucoup beaucoup de
nos enfants est aussi bien entendu nous
devons faire en sorte de préparer
l'avenir et le fait que les et les
établissements soit ouvert je dirais
sont un gage de ce que sera l'avenir
mais je le répète il faut à tout prix
que nous apprenions et tous
collectivement ce que c'est que la
discipline individuelle ainsi que la
discipline collective
il ya trop de l'intervenant qui sont ni
carte son étal beaucoup du protocole
sanitaire en mots aussi de
l'enseignement est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
élèves peuvent apprendre correctement
comme si de rien n'était aujourd'hui le
cas général me conduit à dire que non
non alors bien entendu il y à des élèves
qui
fonctionne qui peuvent fonctionner en
parfaite autonomie mais c'est loin très
très loin d'être le cas de la majorité
d'entre eux est donc il faut à tout prix
qu'il y ait un enseignant qui supervise
qui anime et justement si on parle plus
précisément de l'école à distance est du
numérique
le numérique c'est une modalité
d'enseignement donc il ne faut pas
opposer les modalités il faut à tout
prix par exemple que nos enseignants que
nos élèves mais aussi que les familles
soient formés à ce mode à cette modalité
pédagogique est aujourd'hui soit pour
des questions de moyens soit pour des
questions de méthode
eh bien nous avons vu surtout avec
l'expérience du premier confinement que
trop souvent cela ne marche pas il ya de
trop grands écarts entre les élèves
entre les familles et ce mode
d'enseignement
aujourd'hui avec dans les conditions
actuelles ne permet pas au contraire
même aveu disant certaine inégalité qui
préexistait merci d'avoir réagi sur
notre antenne gérard premier président
de la peep la fédération des parents
d'élèves de l'enseignement public